In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 28, on which we commemorate, are venerable
and God-bearing Father, Memenon, the Wonderworker.
Our Holy Father Memenon renounced the world for love of God and became renowned both for his
ascetic struggles and his holy obedience.
Known as abbot, he guided his monks with gentleness and charity, and thus received from
the Lord the grace to work miracles.
It happened at one time that a cloud of locusts descended on the monastery.
The holy abbot went outside and began to pray, and the locusts disappeared as though consumed
by fire.
By his prayers he also made a springgush forth for the refreshment of the monks and the pilgrims.
He also appeared to some sailors who, caught in a storm, had appealed to him for help,
and guided their ship to save harbor.
For the rest of his life, Saint Memenon was a source of miracles and divine consolation
for all who turned to him in faith.
Having thus lived an exemplary and god-pleasing life, he found with confidence the rest promised
to the glorious who are enriched with the treasures of virtue.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.